oh my God yeah
I don't know what the [ __ ] I do it says
we have a strong connection I've had
like six drinks and I'm just getting
really
really irritated right now really really
irritated I still don't have
um
I'd also have the notification that the
stream started so I'd imagine not
everybody's here yet
but um yeah [ __ ] terrible this one
doesn't have anything in the title so
we'll see if it has anything to do with
what the title was I don't trust I mean
I'll change this title later but I'm
just saying this like I was just getting
really annoying or maybe I've been
traveling around that [ __ ] title
because although like I said dude this
should happen like in 1993 why are
people still [ __ ] worry about that
[ __ ] nowadays thank you Elsa because
it's it because it can be construed as
anti-government and then what's been
happening recently can be construed as
anti-government so they think you might
be
supporters of a certain population for a
certain politician talking about the
evils of the [ __ ] Victor says calm
down have some money might be I'm trying
I'm trying thank you very much but the
more the more I drink the more irritated
again
where the [ __ ] is the I never did get
the um
okay Mark says they'd be confused from
cult to penis and veg juice topics well
well you know I'm just saying look I'm
not making this [ __ ] up I'm not pulling
that [ __ ] out that's just allegedly look
at that
see I'm [ __ ] suspicious now look how
good that quality is
I'm just I'm just saying Jenny now look
at what our stream connection is
yeah it's giving me yellow again yeah
and I never got a notification let's get
into you it's not receiving enough video
to maintain smooth streaming why is this
happening I don't know
God damn it
stream settings
stop it
don't whine about it try to do something
about it like what can we can we reduce
can we reduce the resolution
no
I don't know
yeah [ __ ] mango says he's got a full
[ __ ] bottle of brandy he's dug in for
the long run
good we are too but I don't know how
I'll go here and I'll be I'm just I'm
getting really really annoyed right so
he says even on your Jonestown Show
YouTube put little [ __ ] links about
fact checking [ __ ] under everything
the FBI is like uh they're mostly
talking about Tom Cruise being gay boss
yeah
well yeah [ __ ] shutting that [ __ ]
down
we're speaking too much truth damn power
according to [ __ ] Taylor although we
we haven't you guys to talk about
anything
I feel like we haven't talked about
anything
um
what if I hard reboot the uh
the uh man I have to do this [ __ ] again
yeah look look at that [ __ ] I'm on a
hard reboot the um what you call it
the router yeah the router
that's what I'm gonna do okay people I'm
gonna reboot the router
be back in a bit
oh my God you're killing me you're
killing me